Bobby further developed his theory of attachment on two fundamental
assumptions. First, a responsible and accessible caregiver, creates a secure
base for a child's development. Second, the primary bonding relationship
becomes a mental mold for all future friendships and love relationships. So,
here, humans are the most defenseless and vulnerable creatures on the planet
the first few months after they're born. We have virtually no ability to do
much of anything, except cry and nurse. Therefore, during the first few years
of life, having a stable, reliable and accessible caregiver is crucial for ones
physical growth, cognitive growth and social growth. It's just crucial for our
very survival. If the caregiver is neglectful or doesn't look after the baby's
needs or even abuses them, then all aspects of the child's development can be
stunted. And here, if a secure attachment forms between the caregiver and the
cared for or the child, then the child grows up thinking that this is how a
relationship works. They're reliable and they're a source of security. And all
future friendships and love relationships start with this assumption. Likewise,
if a child is neglected and didn't form a secure attachment, then that's the
assumption the person takes with them through all of their life relationships.